let's go with this Sicilian okay ah well
could enter those veteran akov Sicilian
or the rasulum oh we've seen this before
what game was this played quick trivia
trivia time what game of the World Chess
Championship was this plate 2012 yes
forbus are coming in with the quick won
their game 10 mm well what do you do
this looks a little silly i might want
to do it though if i do this i don't
like this move
let's try that it's a little weird I'm
going to do it though and I'm not in a
position to really just play here as a
follow up because I think there's a
night sack or can i push take stakes
clean out check that's brutal if I block
there's queen here I drop my rook let's
not do that about night e 72 g6
I think that could work
let's try that I have to be a little bit
cautious of like the night moving in the
Queen giving check but I think I have
everything quite all right in that
situation all right let's go here I'm
falling behind a little bit with
development but I am focused on
potential pond breaks if this happens my
pawns do on double just by my bishop
here or here if I go here and this pawn
push happens then my bishop is a little
bit sensitive let's do this if this pawn
break happens I want to be able to play
this move soon but that's not happening
is it okay well let's get castled first
now now the F file is going to open up
and I could really end up with the giant
pond center maybe you guys should have
played a 5 there and then just d6 cuz
now wait a second how do i get my light
square Bishop working actually I'm
threatening to get it working working in
a little bit capturing a couple times on
this square follow up with d 6 and then
pond push that's how I activated I
really do need to be concerned about
that guy and I am actually considering
taking with my pawn
looks a bit weird but if i go here night
here is a bit annoying i got the pump
giant pond center big pond center here
comes d5 big bad d5 here what do i do if
h4 is play it I probably bump my rook up
so my night could come back to f8 and my
rook and maybe come over here and now
I'm gonna go here now I have a fork
threat big Center very big Center on
push only delays my expansion in the
center for so long I just take and here
comes be five
okay here we go i think this is now
trouble ponds are pushing forward here
tsunami of puns to fork by force maybe
the best line is Bishop back pond here
Bishop here but even so two minor pieces
for the rook I'm gonna go for its fine
with that get the Queen's off you know
let's just get the Queen's off and then
how to recapture or do I even recapture
since it was this rook that captured now
I could take here and beyond the rook so
I'm going to do that first now I'll take
here and because I want to get my king
working and last stage is well let's
scoot the King over a little bit more
watch over this so i could play my
bishop to this square I don't want to
allow a pig to land here no no rooks
allowed its number one priority right
now for me don't allow these rugs to get
to the second seventh-ranked that we can
light squares I am ok with the rook
coming here now because this night is
pinned and unprotected and now White's
running into another fork because of the
tough situation this is something to
definitely try and avoid if you're if
you see that your opponent can not only
pin if you have a piece that could be
pinned and it happens to be unprotected
it's very difficult to get out of that
so take with the bishop guard this
flight Square and now there's back rank
issues I'm okay with this rook getting
active I just come over here and
threaten the back rank stuff
alright good game Chronos let's back up
back up flip it from your perspective
now let's see what is the story
following game five up until this point
right here or game I say game 5 game 10
game 10 saw the move be 3 by anand and
then an e5 move that was really neat but
we don't have that in this one we have
night here the the moves are be 3d three
and castle so not so sure about the
Knights III move I know in many lines it
might be advantageous to maybe play
something like c4 to stop these guys in
their tracks but if you're bringing the
night out so early like that not as not
as a you know not not a strong
possibility for these as c4 most um what
else what else am I trying to say here
so okay I mean you went with Knight c3
f6 I don't know what the I don't know if
this is a good move or not but I was I
really didn't want to deal with the e5
move I'm if there's a drawback it's that
I don't have a lot of development but
then again if I am given enough time to
complete my development then this starts
to become an overwhelming center now I
think you after trying to like get
something like f foreign or maybe d4 I
think if you just kind of sit I'm not
going to end up having any problems
maybe even maybe something like h4 h5 to
keep this night around might be
something you could be thinking about
rook e1 I get more development in and
now that's an exchange of a center pond
for one of the flank ponds and this
starts to become just too much I would
be hesitant looking back on this again
I'm hesitant to go at this night move
consider castle here or even d3
having ponds on light squares reinforce
this go with the e5 move maybe if you
can let's say maintain it there if you
have enough support for it but it was
eventually coming under a lot of heat
and I don't know if it was a good choice
to run with the e5 when you did so maybe
maybe work with some other moves at this
points to the Knights III and he just
got to be way too much in the center
these guys it's like a five looks like
like a four on one or something it's
just way too much to deal with I think